-Here at "Late Night,"
we pride ourselves
on digging a little deeper,
so we´re going to bring you
some news you might have missed
in a segment we call
"Did You Know?"
♫♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
Since Trump sided with Democrats
on a deal
to increase the debt ceiling,
the relationship between
Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell
and President Trump
has been very tense.
Luckily, Mitch McConnell
can shield himself
from most of Trump´s anger
by just going back
into his shell.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Leave him alone!
-What?
-Leave him alone.
[ Light laughter ]
Haven´t we made fun
of Mitch McConnell enough?
-Well, he´s a public figure,
so I think it´s okay
to make jokes about him.
-Leave him alone.
[ Light laughter ]
Poor guy.
He´s having a hard time,
and the last thing he needs
is to turn on the TV
only to see you roasting him
over the comedy coals.
[ Light laughter ]
Leave him alone!
[ Laughter ]
-I´m sorry. Are you
a Mitch McConnell supporter?
-If I´m a supporter of anything,
it´s kindness,
not mean-spirited jokes.
If you have to make fun
of somebody, make fun of me.
[ Light laughter ]
-I don´t even know you.
How would I make fun of you?
-Well, you could
make fun of the fact
that my chest hair is so thick,
I once lost a cookie in there
for a week.
[ Laughter ]
-That´s not something
you should just tell people.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, what about this?
You could make fun of the fact
that I write my name
in my underwear,
not so I don´t lose them,
but to pretend
I´m a famous underwear designer.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, the thing is, you know,
we usually tell jokes about
people that are in the news,
like Mitch McConnell.
-Oh, sure,
make fun of Mitch McConnell.
Have your fun.
Go ahead and say he looks like
an old testicle come to life.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoa! That was very harsh.
-I know! So leave him alone!
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, man, I´d just like
to get back to my jokes.
-Want a joke?
Joke about me.
-Oh, man.
-You could make fun of the fact
that my baby teeth
never fell out,
so the inside of my mouth
looks like a shark´s.
[ Light laughter ]
-Sir,
why don´t you just sit down
so we can continue the show?
-Fine.
[ Light laughter ]
Do whatever you want.
-Where´d you get that
[Chuckling] cookie?
-From my...head hair.
-All right, you know what?
[ Laughter ]
Just let me get back to my show.
-Go ahead and get back
to your high-brow
Mitch McConnell turtle jokes.
You know what I say to that?
-I´m guessing,
"Leave him alone"?
-Leave him alone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you! Thank you!
[ Applause ]
That´s right.
If you need someone
to make fun of, make fun of me!
-Oh, man.
-Make fun of the fact that
my mother nursed me
until I was 4 years old,
and then again from 5 to 32!
[ Laughter ]
Or make fun of the fact that
the song
I always pick for karaoke
is "Puff, the Magic Dragon,"
even though I can´t
get through it without crying
or peeing my pants.
[ Laughter ]
Or make fun of the fact that
my favorite food to eat
on the toilet is everything
or that I set an alarm on my
phone to remind me when to fart.
-Why do you need a reminder?
-I don´t want them to back up.
[ Beeping ]
Oops.
[ Flatulence ]
[ Laughter ]
-All right, we´ve heard enough.
It looks like you got your wish,
because we´re out of time,
so I can´t do
any more Mitch McConnell jokes.
-Just leave him alone!
[ Laughter ]
[ Beeping ]
[ Flatulence ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-We´ll be right back with more
"Late Night," everybody!